family raises a 250 pound dog for two
years and then realizes it's a bear
what
at what point are you like
this dog is getting big
how do you not know
a dog is a bear like so you raising it
and it's just eating stuff
it's eating you out of house and home
it's getting huge and then in the story
The couple was saying like yeah we were
kind of getting concerned that the dog
was walking on his hind legs
this bear should Aid both of them
imagine the look on the vet's face
when you walk in first of all when you
walk in with a bear on a leash
and that suckers
walking next to them on the time lapse
and you know and they acted like this as
normal yeah uh fluffy is
um walking like this it's kind of is
there something going on and the
doctor's gonna be like that's a bear
dummy